[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
ici à bruxelles pour ce nouveau numéro
d' europe hebdo
au sommaire encore et toujours le bras
exit un peu plus d'un mois de la date
fatidique du 29 mars
rien n'est réglé c'est le grand flou et
cela se répercute sur les eurodéputés
britanniques
que font-ils en attendant cette date
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre dans
les couloirs du parlement ce sera
l'objet de la deuxième partie de cette
émission mais d'abord rien ne va plus
entre la france et l'italie
paris a rappelé son ambassadeur pendant
huit jours
retour sur une crise diplomatique
inédite depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale entre les deux pays transalpin
regardez
c'était le 5 février sur son compte
twitter le vice-premier ministre italien
poste cette photo luigi di maio cravate
rouge pose au côté d'une dizaine de
gilet jaune avec ce commentaire
le vent du changement a traversé les
alpes une brève rencontre qui a lieu en
france dans le plus grand secret entre
le chef du mouvement 5 étoiles et les
contestataires français paris dénonce
une provocation inacceptable et rappelle
son ambassadeur
la france a fait depuis plusieurs mois
l'objet d'accusations répéter d'
attaques sans fondement de déclarations
outrancières que chacun connaît et peut
avoir à l'esprit
cela n'a pas de précédent depuis la fin
de la guerre à la lumière de cette
situation sans précédent le gouvernement
français a décidé de rappeler
l'ambassadeur de france en italie pour
des consultations le lendemain le vice
premier ministre persiste nous nous
sommes n
si le gouvernement français se mettent
en colère contre le gouvernement italien
je ne crois pas que ce soit aux portes
n'ont jamais cessé de tendre la main la
france
mais si tendre la main à la france ni
fille ne pas pouvoir dialoguer avec les
forces politiques en dehors dans marche
alors je crois que ce concept est
erronée depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
la coalition populiste en italie les
sujets de désaccord entre paris et rome
sont innombrables sur l'immigration
clandestine sur les terroristes italiens
des années de plomb réfugie en france
sur les contrôles aux frontières pour
les travailleurs transfrontaliers fin
janvier luigi di maio accuse même la
française d'appauvrir l'afrique et
d'aggraver la crise migratoire
le lendemain c'est matteo salvini
l'autre vice premier ministre et chef de
la ligue du nord qui cible le président
français avec une violence fort peu
diplomatique
j'espère que les français pourront se
libérer d'un très mauvais président et
l'occasion est celle du 26 mai quand
finalement le peuple français pourra
reprendre en main son avenir et son
destin son orgueil mal représentée par
un personnage comme emmanuel macron
réponse cinglante de la ministre
française des affaires européennes notre
intention n'est pas de jouer au concours
celui qui est le plus bête
nous avons beaucoup de choses à faire
avec un voisin important qui est
l'italie voulons continuer à pouvoir
travailler
est ce que pour autant le climat permet
toutes les visites ministérielles
comme si de rien n'était je me rendrai
en italie quand le climat sera apaisée
quelques semaines plus tard le climat ne
semble pas vraiment apaisé même si
l'ambassadeur de france est reparti à
rome le 15 février après huit jours
d'absence
[Musique]
et pour en parler j'étais zir de
recevoir sur ce plateau david carretta
bonjour bonjour à vous vous êtes
correspondant à bruxelles de la radio
italienne radio radical et alors est ce
que la crise est vraiment profonde entre
la france et l'italie
oui absolument les sans précédent vous
l'avez dit vous-même
c'est la première fois depuis 1940 que
la france rappelle son ambassadeur à
l'époque c'était quand l'italie avait
déclaré tardivement guère à une france
déjà à genoux aujourd'hui la situation
est très différente en europe mais on a
en italien gouvernement qui a besoin de
déclarer des guerres politiques ailleurs
pour cacher ses difficultés internes
un gouvernement qui est en campagne
électorale permanente et il a décidé que
manuel maquereau et le principal la
cible de cette guerre est ce que cette
détérioration des relations inquiète en
italie ou au contraire est-ce qu'il
vient à la montée d'un sentiment anti
français
il ya sûrement la montée de ce sentiment
anti-français qui n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
il était déjà présent dans le passé
beaucoup d'italiens la classe politique
aussi les les gens dans les rues
souffrez un petit peu de cette relation
ou l'italie est vue comme la petite
soeur de la france mais là on arrive à
un nouveau à un niveau supérieur très
dangereux parce que il ya deux pays qui
sont ensemble en europe qui sont alliés
dans le temps
ces deux pays fondateurs de l'union
européenne ces deux pays qui ont des
relations économiques et commerciales
très très fort et là il ya plus de
collaboration il ya vraiment un
gouvernement qui est hostile à l'autre
l'autre qui est contraint réagir à des
provocations continues des provocations
qui n'ont rien à voir avec la réalité
des faits est juste pour des raisons
politiciennes alors j'aimerais qu'on
écoute l'intervention de guy verhofstadt
l'eurodéputé libéral et ancien premier
ministre belge
a strasbourg il s'est livré un véritable
réquisitoire contre l'italie il
s'adressait à guillou cp compter le
premier ministre italien écouter
[Musique]
il m'a gouvernement qu'est pizza râteau
sauter il vostro goven au christ tel
problème à s'auto salvini s'auto di maio
dit ferri capi dit yves erika pudique
reste au gouvernement
on gouverne au camp nou comportementaux
seigneur conti a voté anti européen et
anti gouvernement appartements et audio
contre contrat triste hatim mbri partie
de la nostra famille européen est ligue
auvergne italiano seniors compliqué non
pas par télérama turan ça comme celio
perry forme à merano str politique a dit
asile et migrations et il signera
salvino et spécialisa tableau carré y
por ti a immigré en ti mé blocs à hanter
la création de l'univers confiné
européenne ue ne verra guardia costières
européen d'une réforme en europe et asie
double hinault à creston même temps et
quest il fatto permis et assure donc un
comportement tation de pâques et
l'italie à la citadine italienne et son
nip ligne a pas gardé par la maque ans
dit christophe politika européen
[Musique]
david carretta est-ce que l'italie est
devenue un facteur de blocage pour
l'europe
absolument c'est un gouvernement qui
veut détruire l'europe
il l'a dit publiquement avant d'arriver
au pouvoir la lega le moment cinq
étoiles et ils sont en train de le faire
il ya eu là la bataille contre bruxelles
sur le budget 2010 9 sur laquelle
l'italie a fait un petit peu marche
arrière
il ya les blocages sur la question
migratoire
il y a eu un hiver au fta tu as raison
d'être aussi sévères avec l'italie
absolument petit le mans il ya il ya eu
un blocage par exemple sur la
reconnaissance de wang wei dos comme
président à intérim du venezuela
c'est très grave pour la première fois
l'italie met son veto sur une décision
de politique étrangère où il faut
l'unanimité
et tout cela pour quoi pour cacher
vraiment les problèmes italien l'italie
est en récession le seul pays européen
il faut le faire oublier aux italiens
l'italie n'a plus de rôle international
parce que les isolés en europe et les
isoler aussi haut niveau disons global
l'italie choisi aujourd'hui un autre
parcours sur la question migratoire par
exemple il ya des polémiques pendant des
jours des jours pour 48 70 huit migrants
à bord des bateaux qui sont bloqués à
l'extérieur de l'italie et on oublie que
chaque année 250 milles italien part de
l'italie et sont des migrants qui vont
dans le reste de l'europe
ça c'est la réalité que ce gouvernement
veut faire oublier comment en attaquant
en détruisant l'europe
on parle de gouvernement mais ce que
l'italie l'italie les italiens dans leur
majorité sont devenus anti-européen je
crois pas il ya certainement comme
un sentiment anti européen qui est très
fort oui si la ligue la ligue du nord
elle vous mon sac et one n'aurait pas
été élu
absolument et mais aussi dans dans ce
que ont défini les partis traditionnels
il ya une tendance de la part de
précédents gouvernements celui de
matières ainsi en particulier de dire
c'est pas notre faute c'est toujours la
faute des autres
si l'économie va mal c'est pas la faute
de l'italie qui n'a pas fait
suffisamment des réformes c'est la faute
de l'europe qui nous imposent de
l'austérité si on va rire les chiffres
ya pas eu de vraie austérité en italie
il ya toujours eu beaucoup de dépenses
publiques souvent liée à la politique
peu de réformes mais qu'en dit tout le
temps c'est la faute de l'europe à la
fin les gens commencent à croire que
c'est vraiment la faute de l'europe
merci beaucoup david carretta d'avoir
été à nos côtés
passons désormais obr excité en
attendant la date du 29 mars que font
les députés européens britanniques au
parlement est ce qu il travaillait ce
qu'ils ont déjà fait leurs valises est
ce qu'ils sont guettés par l'ennui
reportage l amont d'un gars va
[Musique]
à bruxelles elle a toujours un oeil rivé
sur londres ajoute kirton darling et une
eurodéputée britannique travailliste
farouchement opposé aux briques site
elle n'épargne pas la première ministre
theresa may chez sai stop
elle est tellement têtu et elle ne veut
vraiment rien changé en fait je pense
qu'elle est un danger pour notre pays en
cette période d'incertitude lié aux
briques site
elle continue à travailler dont la
commission du commerce international et
s'intéresse ce jour-là au dossier liées
à l'acier
elle veut croire que la voix
britanniques comptent encore en europe
autre réunion sur un accord commercial
avec singapour
les eurodéputés britanniques jouent
toujours un rôle très important par
exemple sur ce traité commercial c'est
un eurodéputé du royaume uni qui est le
rapporteur en chef pour le parlement
européen
donc on travaille toujours dur même si à
londres c'est toujours le chaos et qu'on
ne sait pas ce que le futur nous réserve
david coburn lui ne regrettera pas
bruxelles
on marche des kilomètres dans les
couloirs du parlement européen c'est
probablement le bâtiment le plus mal
conçus au monde des kilomètres à
parcourir pour se rendre au moins au
rendez vous soit vous passez une heure à
attendre un ascenseur soit vous marchez
cet élu du ukip travaille encore lui
aussi ce matin direction la commission
des affaires financières et monétaires
pour une réunion sur l'évasion fiscale
il défend tendre exit dur et se rappelle
encore son émotion quand il est retourné
au parlement européen
après le vote des britanniques
oui on n'aime pas vraiment se vanter ce
n'est pas très anglais d'en faire toute
une histoire mais très calmement on a
montré qu'on était effectivement très
heureux et bien sûr ça a énervé un
certain nombre de gens ici tous les
eurobéats il espère bien faire ses
cartons pour de bon le 29 mars prochain
une sortie de l'union européenne fin
mars
c'est bien ce qui reste pour l'heure
prévu une réunion a eu lieu pour
expliquer le processus aux eurodéputés
britanniques
nate angie était lui aussi est un
partisan du brésil on nous a dit que
quatre ou cinq jours après le 29 mars
si le royaume uni quitte bien l'union
européenne ce jour là nos badges
fonctionneront toujours nous pourrons
aller dans nos bureaux finir la
paperasse et en tant qu'ancien membre du
parlement européen nous pourrons
toujours rentrer ici donc qu'on ne va
pas nous claquer la porte au nez
mais une sortie le 29 mars n'est pas le
seul scénario sur la table le royaume
uni pourrait demander à rester un peu
plus longtemps dans l'union européenne
mais jusqu'à quand le 18 avril date de
fermeture du parlement avant les
élections européennes
le 1er juillet date de l'installation
des nouveaux eurodéputés
certains se prennent même à rêver à de
nouvelles élections européennes au
royaume uni
jean lambert europhile convaincu 20 ans
au parlement européen veut y croire et
mon plus grand espoir est que le royaume
uni reste et qu'il y ait toujours des
eurodéputés britanniques
j'aurais adoré faire campagne pour mon
successeur c'est ce que j'avais prévu de
faire avec envie avant que le peuple
n'en décide autrement
je pense qu'il ya une chance très mince
mais il ya une chose à vrai dire à cinq
semaines de leur départ supposé les
eurodéputés britanniques sont bien
incapables de prédire ce qu'il va se
passer mais comme la firme sajjad karim
conservateurs opposés au président
ils peuvent compter sur le soutien de
leurs collègues d'autres pays européens
[Musique]
je peux voir la frustration des
collègues des autres pays européens
mais à chaque fois que je discute avec
eux ils me disent qu'ils sont prêts à
nous donner plus de temps pour que le
royaume uni trouve enfin une solution
c'est la première fois de toute
l'histoire de l'union européenne qu'un
pays souhaitent la quitter
une situation inédite
dont l'issue reste inconnu à bruxelles
[Musique]
et pour parler du brésil trois invités
ont rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour
karima delli vous êtes députée
européenne française membres ici du
groupe des verts à vos côtés monsieur
corbett bonjour eurodéputé britannique
travailliste membre du groupe de
l'alliance des socialistes et démocrates
et britanniques aussi monsieur charles
tannock bonjour eurodéputés jour du
groupe des conservateurs et réformistes
alors dans le reportage on voit une de
vos collègues britanniques rêver encore
de faire campagne pour les européennes
comme si le breakbeat n'allait pas
existé après le 29 mars est ce qu'il y
aura encore des députés européens
vous serez au bout c'est probable il ya
une possibilité mais les très petites
maintenant si le leader du parti
travailliste veut soutenir appuyé l'idée
d'une deuxième référendum il ya une
petite possibilité mais c'est absolument
certain que monsieur copé ne veut pas
une deuxième refrain il est en brique
sida ils veulent ils il veut bien le
black seeds et malheureusement on est
dans la position que mon parti le
gouvernement britannique veut une sortie
assez dur dubrac sites est monsieur copé
ne veut la même chose alors il n'y a pas
opposition au président dont le
parlement national malheureusement là à
mon avis dans le cas qu'il n'y a pas
d'accord il y à une kawa une catastrophe
économique peut-être madame mais y
changera d'avis et elle est peut-être
elle donnera son appui politique en
deuxième les frais ne me serais pas
probable c'est pas c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup plus probable que dans quelques
semaines on ne sera plus membre de
l'union européen malheureusement quel
est votre sentiment vous monsieur
corbett dans cette période d'attentes
d'inconnus oui c'est bien de parler de
monsieur cobain mais c'est quand même
les conservateurs qui sont au
gouvernement qui nous mène dans cette
direction vers un break site assez
catastrophique
la position du parti travailliste de
s'opposer à l'accord que madame et à
négocier qui est un mauvais un mauvais
accord et si nous ne parvenons pas à
trouver un autre accord alors de revenir
au peuple pour un nouveau référendum
à ce moment là on veut pas partir sans
accord ça c'est le carrosse
on veut pas de cet accord qui est
mauvais s'il n'y a pas de possibilité de
trouver un autre accord il va bien
falloir repenser le break 6 et selon les
sondages d'opinion au s'il y avait un
nouveau référendum au royaume uni il y
avait une majorité pour rester dans
l'union mais ça veut dire quoi madame
délit ça veut dire que le brésil
pourrait être repoussée on pourrait
repousser après la date du 29 mars
attendre encore un peu des semaines des
mois
qu'en pensez vous est ce que c'est une
hypothèse plausible alors actuellement
theresa may joue la montre c'est à dire
elle veut absolument avoir un délai
supplémentaire
mais quoi qu'il arrive ce délai va avoir
un impact sur les élections européennes
c'est ça et dans ce cas là c'est très
simple si le délai est trop lourd et
prolonge et prolongé après les élections
européennes
juridiquement les le royaume uni doit
présenter des candidats pour les
élections européennes
ça veut dire quoi concrètement ils ont
un double problème politiquement comment
quel discours y tiennent quel type de
compagnies vont faire sachant que après
les élections européennes et c'est là le
drame
on pourrait avoir des députés qu'ils
soient là ici pendant trois mois et
après les trois mois il serait plus
députés ce qui pose aussi un problème de
fond dans la composition et
l'organisation des élections oui est ce
que là tout est un peu trancher les
places des députés britanniques
voilà mais déjà au fait à d'autres pays
ofae donc ce qui se passe c'est que cela
c'est la répartition de 2014 qui
s'appliquerait pour les élections du 26
mai prochain
et après on nous rit nouvelles
compositions par exemple dans mon pays
on à 74 députés en france et si vous
sortiez est bon on aurait 79 donc ont
récupéré après coup cinq députés
européens après l'élection donc c'est
pas possible
moi je considère aujourd'hui c'est que
on est dans une zone de turbulences et
d'urgence c'est-à-dire que chaque
britannique notamment responsable
politique doit prendre justement un acte
majeur
on ne peut plus jouer avec la vie
des citoyens on a un accord sur la table
d'accord on a eu la main tendue par
monsieur jeremy corbyn les travaillistes
ont dit à blesmes theresa may on est
prêts à voter cet accord si vous
maintenez l'union douanière et ensuite
on a et avec des propositions qui sont
assez intéressantes et on a theresa may
qui nous dit mais c'est pas possible
parce que ça va encore divisée justement
mon propre parti la problématique
elle est là c'est à dire que ce break
site aujourd'hui qui est un jeu de poker
menteur parce que c'était quand même
campagne où on a dit beaucoup de fiefs
news ou s'arrêter n'importe quoi je
tiens juste à dire que nous les
européens on aime l'angleterre
nos voisins ce sont les britanniques 1
et moi je le regrette
qui sans plus mais ils ne se rendent pas
compte des conséquences concrètes de la
sortie de l'union européenne et alors
cette semaine theresa may a repris les
discussions avec les 27
plusieurs ministres et dirigeants
britanniques sont venus ici à bruxelles
notamment rencontré michel barnier le
négociateur pour l'union européenne
alors est ce que les choses frémissait
ce que les choses bougent est ce qu'il
ya des négociations en coulisses ou pas
monsieur mittal à discuter les
négociations ont fini à décembre
l'accord est déjà fait elle a déjà
essayé d'avoir l'appui du parlement
national pour l'accord qui a été appuyé
par les vingt-sept et aussi le
gouvernant gouvernement et le parlement
national a échoué ça je crois pas qu il
y a la possibilité de rouvrir le texte
légal de la torre peut-être la
déclaration politique c'est possible de
changer un peu
mais le problème c'est que madame mais
elle ne veut pas changer ses lignes
rouges
elle est contre tout bêtement contre
l'idée de rester dans le marché interne
dont l'union douanière sous la
juridiction du duc o justice et tout ça
à mon avis y changera un peu ses idées
sur ces choses là il ya la possibilité
d'avoir un appui dans le parlement
national mais elle sait très bien que si
elle fait ça il
le mon parti sera divisé dont le
parlement national parce que l'extrême
droite du parti réagit le groupe
autre héros steppiques ils veulent
qu'elle reste avec ses lignes rouges et
c'est très difficile de trouver une
majorité dans le parlement national ou à
coca solution et ça c'est très simple
c'est ça c'est le grand problème à mon
avis est possible que la semaine
prochaine il y aura un amendement qui
obligera le gouverment en nationale 2 et
enlever le nom accords de la table et
d'avoir une prolongation prolongement du
29 mars
peut-être pour trois mois jusqu'à la fin
de juin avant la nouvelle session du
prochain parlement l'homme ne veut pas
la mort ça c'est possible c'est possible
temps de renégocier un petit pour une re
négocier peut-être avoir une deuxième
réfrène ne peut-être avoir des élections
anticipées
il ya beaucoup de possibilités mais on
aura trois mois pour y penser bien après
ça c'est très difficile si on n'a pas si
on ne fait pas les élections et
européens
il y assure temps la jouerie ce qu'ils
disent que c'est possible qu' on ne
participe à participer rappaz dans les
élections et il y aura des députés
nationaux qui seront deux deviendront
des héros député pendant une année mais
ça il faut un changement des traités
c'est très compliqué ce 1er également ça
paraît très très compliqué monsieur
corbett
là on a l'impression qu'on est dans le
même état la même situation qu on
décembre qu'est-ce qui entrent dans les
négociations entre le royaume uni et l
union européenne qu est ce qui peut
changer qu'est-ce qui peut bouger on
sait plus vraiment précisément c'est ça
la question parce que depuis le mois de
décembre
rien n'a bougé et cerise amère revient
maintenant aujourd'hui à bruxelles elle
veut rouvrir les négociations sur un
point précis le soi-disant bac stop de
filet de sauvetage si vous voulez
question de la frontière irlandaise en
fait elle veut déchirer l'accord de paix
qu'il ya eu il ya 20 ans en irlande
c'est quand même
c'est quand même assez choquant et il ya
une résistance à ça naturellement de la
part de l'irlande et des 27 mais aussi
au royaume uni partout il ya bien
d'autres problèmes avec cet accord va
pas celui là et vous karima delli qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
est-ce qu'on est toujours au point mort
est ce que vous pensez que donc madame
thérèse à metz joue ce qu'on peut
appeler la stratégie de la peur est que
jusqu'au dernier moment et elle va dire
au dernier moment où à son parlement on
regarde et on n'a pas le choix il faut
voter il faut voter
d'abord il ya plusieurs choses à dire la
première chose c'est que depuis ce
référendum
l'union européenne à respecter la voix
des citoyens en disant vous voulez
sortir et donc vous allez sortir ça
c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose qui est apte
importante
merci michel barnier ça fait plus de
deux ans qu'on négocie c'est cet accord
un plus de deux ans ça veut dire qu'on a
fait aussi beaucoup de concessions
aujourd'hui on a une base de travail ou
les vingt-sept ne bougeront plus sur cet
accord c'est terminé
la balle revient dans le camp maintenant
des britanniques et je pense qu'il faut
que tout le monde notamment les
responsables britanniques
il faut qu'ils prennent leurs
responsabilités de manière grande on
peut plus jouer sur ce braquage
responsabilité justement arrêté le break
si justement moi je me dis moi depuis 7
mois depuis le début je dis j'espère
qu'il y aura un accord parce que si le
faire et quand même d'arrêter la
pratique non mais moi c'est moi c'est
clair et net je ne suis pas pour le
break 6-3 lors d'émissions encore
vraiment de chance et nous faisons je
suis pour qu'on ait un temps pour qu'on
ait un accord la problématique n est pas
la suivante c'est que si theresa may
gagne du temps pour gagner du temps ci
au point final c'est la même chose à
dire c'est ce qu'elle avait dit au début
donc là vous nous expliquer qu'on fait
c'est un bel alibi interne mais c'est un
problème interne voulait négocier
sur les visions de mon parti qu'a fait
donc le problème il est que si elle
demande encore trois mois de
négociations elle veut que si elle est
opposée
je crois moi je ne peux pas faut pour
avoir les mêmes conclusions ça ne sert à
rien donc maintenant la véritable
question elle est sûre le 29 mars qu'est
ce qui va se passer le 29 mars
si on n'a pas d'accord quelles vont être
les conséquences des lendemains
et moi je dis que c'est ça qu'il faut
préparer c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous au parlement européen et vous êtes
comme moi on a travaillé sur un bouclier
législatif pour essayer d'amoindrir les
conséquences je vais donner un exemple
très concret les transports moi je suis
la présidente de la commission
transports on a fait tout un dispositif
pour éviter toute paralysie dans le ciel
dans le secteur maritime ou même sur le
fret de marchandises mais c'est
provisoire parce qu'après le 29
qu'est ce qui se passe négocier et c'est
là où les anglais doit être responsable
c'est que vous allez avoir un moment de
savoir quel statut vous voulez avoir
après le 29 mars et alors on a longtemps
là on a le pardon on a longtemps eu
l'impression que le no deal c'était
l'épouvantail pour les européens pour
les négociateurs ici et en ce moment on
a peut-être l'impression que finalement
ce serait la moins pire des solutions
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
moi je pense pas que ce soit la moins
pire des solutions c'était d'ailleurs
que les conséquences d'un non accords
vont être terribles
je vais vous donner un exemple très très
concret même si on a fait un filet de
sécurité
quand vous voit des marchandises et
qu'on doit équiper des ports aujourd'hui
ils n'ont pas en france avec des
contrôles douaniers des contrôles
sanitaires des contrôles vétérinaires
pareil pour les anglais ils vont devoir
s'équiper et bien vous allez voir que
les prix vont augmenter
monsieur labonté est aussi il faudra une
frontière du rire au nez
au terrorisme que moi j'ai je me
souviens bien de ça dont les années 70
80 il ya beaucoup de problèmes avec le
nom accor c'est vrai qu'on essaye
maintenant d'avoir une gestion d'une
l'accord avec les émotions qu'on a voté
à strasbourg la semaine dernière sur la
question de transport aérien traces des
droits des passagers tout ça mais en en
vacances est désastreux pour l'accès aux
maîtres aux médecins aux médecines la
collection des prix des produits de la
nourriture et tout ça à distribution de
l'insuline par exemple aux malades tout
ça va être un enjeu est très aisé et il
y aura un impact négatif sur l'économie
c'est en effet le move en taille mais
madame ben et elissa pour faire du
chantage les voiles à sortir son accord
c'est une catastrophe
donc il faut accepter mon accord bidon
et elle veut pas prolonger au-delà elle
veut pas une extension au delà du 22
mars parce que elle veut utiliser ce
moyen de chantage pour faire fort
beaucoup de britanniques des noms ont
fait pas sentir sans accord évidemment
non je parle de votre mauvais accord non
plus
alors là il reste seulement deux
possibilités logiquement soit on peut
faire un autre accord hypothèse qui qui
devient de plus en plus chaque jour
ou bien il faut changer d'avis sur le
break 6 donc juridiquement très très
facile politiquement il faut faire un
nouveau référendum
ce sera le mot de la fin merci à tous
pour votre participation et merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis à très bientôt je
vous souhaite une bonne semaine
[Musique]